each week on the dish we have chefs
share their food and oftentimes a new
cookbook and while we talk about the
food on the pages within the photos
often go overlooked until this morning
evans sung is a lifestyle and travel
photographer behind some of those very
delectable images he's found a way to
combine his passions with his chef's
foods to give us so much more than just
a taste of the dishes so let's see where
your hands would be creating a great
cookbook requires all the right
ingredients a collaboration of chef
stylist can I just tweet something this
real quick and photographer Ivan Basso
crop all must be aligned to capture the
perfect plate easier done than described
according to acclaimed food photographer
Evan song it's hard to articulate
sometimes it's just a feeling of that
looks right or that something doesn't
look right there every dish that comes
up as a surprise every image is a little
story you're trying to tell the
photographs meant to compliment the
recipe for a dish are works of art in
their own right so then yes this chicken
should come in huh
the most exciting part of the cookbook
for me has been the photography process
the dish itself looks good awesome and
seeing your food come to life
in just a few months this one from chef
Ashiya Gomez and sung will end up in a
book store like books are magic in songs
Brooklyn neighborhood this was a book we
did with Padma Lakshmi and the amazing
spice store Colossians
it's like encyclopedia of just different
spice blends sung has photographed a
who's-who of culinary royalty including
sushi chef morimoto butcher Pat LaFrieda
and Baker Dominique and Sal who released
everyone can bake last month it's the
latest in songs catalog which now fills
an entire book show any standouts that
you can show me sure we looked at 2015
Senegal by Harlem chef Pierre Cheon how
the color that's beautiful the pair took
three trips to capture Shyam's home
country I'm just excited to be seeing
everything and meeting all these people
eating street food the people are just
amazing looking the landscape the
Wardrobe so it was about capturing a
whole country experiences like that
inspire the 44 year old song shooting
food requires some sensitivity and
technical know-how but shooting the food
just by itself is not for me the end
goal you know it's it's connecting to
something larger than that when you
first picked up that camera could you
have imagined what you are doing now
yeah not at all
it sort of feels like surfing in a way
you just sort of you catch the wind you
catch the wave and just kind of go that
way of thinking originally led some to
study philosophy at NYU he was studying
literature in California when he broke
up with his girlfriend and abruptly
moved home taking refuge in his emerging
hobby just felt like going home with my
tail between my legs and photography was
something that really was helping me
process a lot of this stuff I was going
through in California or self-portraits
just exploring that creative side cliche
I'm not sure but it felt like a great
outlet and then something clicked my
parents have always been really
supportive and they just asked me so do
you think you can make any
what are you doing it I said I don't
know okay well good luck he found work
as an assistant in a stock photography
studio before embarking on a long shot
trip to Paris I decided okay I'm an
experienced assistant in New York should
be no problem to find work out there the
hubris of you yeah exactly exactly so I
went out I mean I have my savings and I
went out and I gave it a shot I was out
there for three weeks four weeks I met
as many people as I could and I just
sort of felt like well I gave it a shot
it's not really gonna work out and then
I met him him is jacquimo bretzel an
Italian photographer who was looking for
an assistant we met we hit it off he
said what are you doing next week I'm
going to Italy I was like I guess I'm
going to leave it taught me that this
little camera could open up so many
doors and really lead to all these
amazing experiences you know after a
year overseas sung moved back to New
York and picked up work for the New York
Sun one of the first things they
assigned me was a restaurant story and I
said oh I know how to shoot food I did
that with Giacomo my photographer in
Paris and they liked it and I liked it
and and it sort of started from there
through his camera some has seen the
world from Senegal to Iceland to
southern India where he traveled with
Atlanta chef Asha Gomes for the New York
Times to see her so full of motion
seeing the country again and seeing the
food again the landscape was really just
the most thrilling Sun Also shot her
first cookbook my two South's
and they've reunited for her second he
allows me to have my creative process
and only when he knows that my process
is complete and I have put that plate of
food down is when he starts his creative
process should we see like more noodle
here or well he's capturing me and the
essence of my food which i think is what
makes a brilliant photographer it's what
he sees but it's not about him it's
about the food and it's about the chef
let's meet the food get that gram when
somebody picks up a cookbook that you've
shot what do you hope they take away
from your photos I mean that's an
interesting question where I'm really
looking is with my collaborator you know
I want them to take away from the image
sort of whatever they have in their
minds I of what they do that it feels
like that so the consumer out there you
know I want them to want the food to
have their appetite awakened and the
desire to make it but yeah ultimately
for me I could also just make it a
little tighter the interest is in the
creation of it yeah I'm here happy then
we're done mission accomplished with all
those photos by the way guys I want to
point out so obviously sung is
completely tied to the restaurant
industry which so many people are
struggling right now so to help all
those employees that are struggling he
start part of a fundraiser on his
Instagram page which is Evan sung NYC
you can go there you can look through
all of his photos for certain costs for
different sizes you can get a print
he'll take sure make sure you get the
print have it printed for you and sent
to you and those funds will then go help
restaurant employees so you can check it
out you know Dana this is a real
specialty I did the dish last week on
the author of Jubilee and she talked
about it taking her a year to find the
perfect photographer for her cookbook
Toni to be Martin found the person and
she went forward as usual while watching
and doing our show I'm hungry
nice job